as Batman historian will Brooker one set
the defining characteristic of Gotham
City must be there is always crime
stalking our city by night and day is on
the increase under man police force is
helpless to cope with the situation but
they have analyzed that man there has to
be crime in Gotham because Batman is on
one key level the one who fights crime
this highlights the inseparable
connection between Batman and his city
it's actually more like a circular
connection and that one is always
creating and perpetuating the other it
was Gotham City that killed Bruce
Wayne's parents in the form of a petty
thief that it's corrupt conditions
created setting in motion a chain of
events that led to the Batman's
obsessive mission to rid Gotham of crime
and obsession that fostered a darker and
more twisted criminality I'm an agent of
chaos in the beginning Gotham was just a
backdrop a setting indeed it wasn't even
Gotham it was New York City until
Detective Comics number 48 in the 1943
and 49 television serials of Batman most
of the action largely due to budgets
takes place in interiors on sound stages
little attempt is made to signify Gotham
as a whole the same is true for the Adam
West Batman series in the 1960s when the
character was at the height of camp
scrubbed through the entire
feature-length movie from 1966 and you
won't see so much as a skyscraper when
the Adam West show failed
Batman writers brought a darker tone to
the stories they brought an extended
continuity and continuity meant that
individual locations in Gotham
importance and the city itself started
to breathe as a character this run of
dark comics culminated in 1986 with
Frank Miller's The Dark Knight Returns
which plumbed the obsessive tortured
psyche of the Batman and found a
counterpoint to that troubled mind in
the diseased crime-ridden streets of
Gotham that essential feeling was
intensified even more and three years
later Gotham City became a nightmare in
what has become the most iconic
imagining of the Caped Crusader's home
Tim Burton and Anton Furst
fashioned the city as if he'll burst
through the pavement and grew drawing
from a number of garishly juxtaposed
architectural styles and the charcoal
drawings of Hugh Ferris the creators of
1989's Batman took the lady's fears of
worsening crime and augmented them to a
Kafka esque level that aesthetic was
made more grand and exaggerated in
Burton's sequel Batman Returns and three
years later Batman Forever depicted a
Gotham that was flashy or colorful
somehow even more removed from reality
finally what was McCobb and genuinely
inspired in Burton's imagination became
gaudy and genuinely ridiculous in 1997's
fourth installment in the series Batman
and Robin Ian as monkey business and yet
as the movies soured Burton's vision of
Gotham television and comics were taking
all the best parts of the 1989 aesthetic
and developing a deeper identity for the
city in the stellar Batman the Animated
Series Gotham City is all dark deco as
if the 1930s World's Fair had gone on
for another 60 years in the comics
Batman was more loathe than ever to
leave Gotham and Gotham itself became
more isolated and separated from the
rest of the world in a famous arc called
no-man's land the national government
chooses to abandon Gotham entirely after
the city is almost destroyed by an
earthquake the island quickly carved up
by gangs and villains becomes a hell
Earth Christopher Nolan made a similar
isolating move in Batman Begins when the
police raised the bridges to stop
escaped criminals from fleeing the city
and again in the Dark Knight Rises when
Bane destroys those bridges of course
Nolan's Gotham is decidedly more
grounded and realistic than its
predecessors especially in the Dark
Knight Burton's Gotham maybe more
nightmarish but a Gotham that resembles
our own world can be even more
terrifying when it's shown to be fragile
in the face of a violent disregard for
the established order from its earliest
on-screen depictions in the 1940s to the
latest in a series of gruesome
videogames and a network TV show that
bears its name Gotham has been flexible
to account for a changing world and a
changing Batman but the one constant is
crime an irrepressible criminal
underclass that plagues the streets with
whom the police are either in league or
powerless to stop indeed the Batman is
by definition unable to stop this
scourge - or else his existence would be
unjustified you are defending a city so
corrupt we have infiltrated every level
of its infrastructure Gotham I think is
totally unique in the history of cities
real or imagined existing for more than
70 years we have an exhaustive knowledge
of its attitude of its feel of places
there like Wayne tower or Arkham Asylum
or Crime Alley yet unlike a real city we
can't map it out in the traditional
sense and every attempt to do so is
subject to change in sort of absurd
Gotham is a city that's performed we
know it by the stories that happen there
by the spaces generated from encounters
in the night in this view it's many
versions don't register as
inconsistencies
but cohere into perhaps a new way to
think of cities as a site of constant
reinvention and varied interpretation as
an expression of the traumas that are
reenacted by those who have suffered and
as a place that can't be mapped by its
buildings and streets but by the events
and people and minds that make them
hey everybody thanks for watching if you
think this is the kind of content that
you're not seeing anywhere else on
YouTube or the internet you can pledge
to my channel by clicking right here
going to my patreon giving as little as
$1 per video this is a full-time job
made possible by you guys
you know these take like 40 or 50 hours
to make I work like 9 or 10 hours a day
doing these and I'm having so much fun
and I think the quality of the content
has gotten better since I've gone
full-time and there's still like a lot
more stuff I want to experiment with and
do and that's all made possible by you
so thanks again there are still some
stickers left nerdwriter stickers $3 a
video you can pledge there get them
there yeah thanks a lot
this Batman video is so much fun to make